I'm Shel a software engineer. I embraced
Islam at the time of my marriage. I just
have only one question which relates to
humanity. Our topic is about peace to
humanity. Does Islam or in anywhere in
Quran is it specified about the woman
organ donation? If it is so, is it
allowed or like why is the reason that
it is not allowed? So as I heard from
some of my
friends as a question that is there any
mention in the Quran that organ donation
can be done or not? There's no verse in
the Quran or any authentic hadith where
organ transplantation organ donation can
be done or cannot done. But all the
scholars have got together and there are
several conferences taking place in
Makkah in Riyad in Malaysia. And the
scholarsly agree that organ donation and
organ transplantation can be done if
three criterias are fulfilled. Number
one, the person donating the organ
should not cause a major loss to his
health. I can't give my heart. If I
donate my heart, I will die.
But doctors say that I've got two
kidneys, one kidney sufficient and that
my mother both the kidneys have failed.
I can give a kidney to her. Even she
will survive and even I will survive. So
point number one, the person donating
the organ should not cause a major loss
to his health. Point number two, the
person receiving the organ should be a
major benefit for his health. Point
number three, it should not be for money
for economic reasons. Person can't sell
his kidney. So if these three things are
fulfilled, the scholars say under these
conditions, organ donation can be done,
organ transplantation can be done. Hope
that answers the question. Please pose
your question. Yeah, my name is Amish. I
got a
question. What do you think? Why God
created us? Do you think he created us
to send here for test in order to
categorize us for heaven or hell?
Well, as the question, why did God
create us? And on the second day of this
conference, I gave a talk on purpose of
creation for about 1 hour 15 minutes. I
don't intend to be the lecture. One of
the reasons is that God created us for
the test of the hereafter. This life as
Quran says in surah m number
two, he has created death and life to
test which of us in good deeds. And
besides that, one of his unique creation
is he created the human beings who have
a free will. We can either obey almighty
god or we may disobey almighty god. We
have been given the free will and
almighty god asked us before we came in
this world who would like to become a
human being. So we opted for that you
and I in the previous life before we
came in this world we opted for that. So
based on that almighty god gave us a
free will. Now after we get free will we
either have the option to obey god or
disobey god. If we obey god we get ja.
If we disobey god then we don't get ja.
So this life is a test for the
hereafter. Other creations angels don't
have a free will. They always obey Allah
subhana wa t'ala. So we opted for the
test. We opted for the test. So we
undergoing the test. So based on this
test, we will get our reward and
punishment. Allah says in the Quran in
surah daria 15:56, Allah
says that we have created jin and the
men not but worship me. So one of the
reasons for our creation is worship and
there's a test for the hereafter. Allah
subhananaa tala does not require us to
worship him. Whether we worship him or
not, he is yet great. It will not
diminish him. It will not make him
superior. We are undergoing the test for
our benefit. We opted. It is like I
opted to appear for the medical
examination. I opted. So the teacher she
corrected okay fine and I passed the
test. So similarly brother we opted and
we undergoing the test and for the
complete answer you can refer to my
video said the purpose of creation.
Yes brother, can we have the next
question from you?
Respected
sir, I have four questions.
First one is brother please hard to
believe please mention your name and one
question at a time.
Uh there are some uh hard to believe
instances in any scriptures. For
instance, uh in Quran like birds
dropping stones in a uh battlefield on
the enemy's uh uh context like that uh
which is hard to
believe. That's my first
question. There's a question. There are
certain things mentioned in the Quran
like birds dropping stones talking about
surah surah chapter number 105. There
are many things for example Quran says
about shakar prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam split the moon into two. Musa
alisam split the sea into two. These are
difficult things. Yes these are known as
miracles. Miracles are those thing which
a human mind cannot conceive how it
happened. For us human
being to make the moon into two is not
possible. First human being to split the
sea into two and have a pathway not
possible. So these are known as miracles
which only god can do you and I cannot
do. So it's difficult for us to
conceive. The only way for us to testify
is to go back into time. You're sitting
now. We can't go
back 3,000 4,000 years back and check up
whether musam Moses did he split the sea
or not. So what we say these are
miracles which doesn't allow us to go
back in time. But there are many things
which Quran has said which has come to
today. For example, Quran speaks about
science about the big bang. Quran speaks
the light of the moon not its own light.
Quran speak the earth is spherical.
Quran speak the sun rotates. Which to a
man 4900 years back would sound what is
this nonsense that the moon has its own
light that the earth is spherical. All
these things about the big bang. But
today after science has advanced we have
come to know it's a fact. But to know
what happened in the past, we can't go
back in time. So what my logic says,
whatever the Quran has mentioned,
certain things we can check up now.
Certain things we can't check up. We
can't go back in time. So that goes in
ambiguous lot. So what things we can
check up today? Out of those things,
whatever we can check up, 80% things we
can check up. So my logic says 80% of
what the Quran mentioned, we can check
up today and we have come to 100%
correct.
Whatever we can check, not even 1% is
wrong. Most of the content are historic.
I think so. Yes, that's what I'm telling
you, brother. A historic for you to say
that thing didn't happen. You can only
prove by going back in time. If the
Quran says prophet Moses split the sea,
you can't prove that he didn't split.
Neither can you prove he split. But we
can't go back in time. Can we go back
3,000 4,000 years back? Can we go? We
can't. So, what we say logically, this
may have happened, may not have
happened. May have happened, may not
have happened. The birds may have
dropped stone, may not have dropped
stone. Correct? What we say this is
ambiguous. If we talk about the nuclear
bomb thousand years back, would they
have believed? Would they have believed?
They would have said this is nonsense.
Right or wrong? But today you and I
believe or not because science will
advance. Similarly, there's nuclear
bomb, there's atom bomb. So birds
dropping stones. What's the problem? It
is so easy. Nuclear bomb is more
difficult. So here we realize we cannot
go back in time. So what my logic says
whatever we can testify today whatever
we can analyze today out of that 100%
has been proved to be correct 20% we
can't analyze we cannot go back we can't
go in future we cannot prove
scientifically whether there's heaven or
hell so you'll ask me brother Zakir
you're a medical doctor how do you
believe in heaven and hell I said that
goes in the 20% ambiguous lot so my
logic says when
80% what we can check today of the Quran
has been 100% to be correct not Even.1%
is wrong. So my logic says what 20% is
ambiguous. Inshallah, God willing, even
that will be correct. Maybe science will
advance after 50 years, after 20 years.
We'll come to know about life after
death. We may come to know about heaven
or hell. So my logic says it's a logical
belief that when not even 0001% has been
proved wrong of the Quran. 80% is 100%
correct. So my logic says inshallah the
20% which we can't verify by going back
in time or going in future even that
inshallah will be correct. Hope that
answers the question. May we have the
next question for brother here.
Hello, I'm Ashoke here. I'm doing my MA
economics in Loyola College. So my
question is that in this time of this
time of this like uh every world is in a
very distressed we are in a way of we
want peace. Whether there is a region
whether it's a religion peace or
whatever it is we need peace. We need
some
humanity and we have lots of people from
outside countries also. So is the
religion is the sole thing that we are
doing so much of problems all around is
the religion is the sole problem for
that we are demolishing the WTO all
around and we have lots of problem over
there and is is the religion is the
solution for the things happening all
around the world and is it the solution
for the people dying in Ethiopia? We
have children dying out of hunger. Is
the solution? Is the religion solution
for them? What is the solution for the
real thing for what we are wondering all
around? Is it the religion is the only
solution for what we are debating all
this time? What I think so we need
solution for that. Thank you. That's a
good question that we having so many
problems in the world. Is religion the
solution for this problem? There are so
many people dying in Ethiopia. Is
religion the solution? Brother, the
religion which is true is the solution.
Allah says in the Quran in surah alim
chapter number 3 verse number 19 in
Islam the only reason acceptable in the
sight of almighty god is submitting a
will to almighty god if every human
being submits the will to almighty god
you won't have a problem inia says in
the Quran and several say hadith that
the third pillar of Islam is every rich
person who has a saving of more than the
nisab level 85 g of gold should give
2.5% of his saving in charity if every
rich human being gives charity poverty
will be eradicated from this
Leave us at Ethopia. There will not be a
single human being anywhere in the world
who will die of
hunger. Do you know that the three
richest men in the world? The three
richest men in the world, their wealth
is equal to 48 poorest countries GDP.
Three richest men, if all of these
people give zakat, it will solve the
problem of the humankind. So the problem
is that if every human being follows
follows the religion of submitting his
will to almighty god like that you gave
one problem. Any problem you get,
alhamdulillah, the glorious Quran has
the solution to the problem. Follow the
right religion and you'll get real
peace.
Do we have a question from the sister's
side? Yeah, there's a question from the
non-Muslim
sister. When a Muslim is in a
non-Muslim's house at the time of
prayer, at the time of salah, can he or
she do his prayer in their house or what
is the right way to do it? And can a
Muslim take
prasad from the temples?
There are two questions. Number one is
can a Muslim pray in the house of a
non-Muslim? As long as there's nothing
which is wrong in the house, as long
there's no idol in the front, as long
the place you're praying is a clean
place, you can pray any part of the
world. Our beloved prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said, it's
mentioned Bkari number one in the book
of Salah that the whole world is a
mosque for the believers. So as long as
the place is
clean and doesn't break any rule of the
Sharia, there's no idol in front you can
very well pray. regarding taking prasad.
Prasad is a food which is given by the
Hindus in the name of dietes and gods.
Allah says in the Quran in no less than
four different play in surah bakar
chapter number 2 verse number 173 in
surah maida chapter number 5 verse
number three in surah nam chapter number
6 verse number 145 and surah chapter
number 16 verse number
115 forbidden for you for food are dead
meat blood the flesh of swine and any
food on which any name besides Allah's
name is taken so
eating is haram it's not permitted in
Islam but we know many Muslims you know
we don't want to offend
We don't want to offend our non-Muslims.
So what they do some of the Muslims they
say bismillah and have
it. So tomorrow you'll say bism and have
alcohol after that and have poke eating
any food on which any name besides
Allah's name is taken is prohiblam. How
to deal with them? You can refer to my
video cassette dawa or distraction which
shows you a way how to convince a
non-Muslim regarding the concept of
prasad and how to convince them through
their scriptures about the true concept.
Hope that answers the question.
The next question